les prix en janvier l'augmentation de
0,5 pour cent chiffres officiels le
football à l'elysée l'équipe de france a
déjeuné avec le chef de l'état refusé
d'ouvrir le coffre de sa voiture lors
d'un contrôle policier c'est un délit un
automobiliste condamné et puis inviter
notre journal des criquets terrorisa
nouveau l'afrique
et là messieurs bonsoir un autocar
franchissant les portes de l'elysée il
paraît que cela ne s'était jamais fait
ce n'était pas des touristes perdus mais
les membres du prestigieux club france
c'est à dire les meilleurs joueurs de
football français valéry giscard
d'estaing les avait conviés à déjeuner
et pour être sûr qu'ils arriveraient
bien à l'heure tous ensemble on les a
donc mis dans un autocar en compagnie
vous allez le voir de leur entraîneur
michel hidalgo et de leurs dirigeants
même les éclopés était la seule
dominique rocheteau aux blessés
avant-hier et des absences on apparaît
s'il parlait que de football mais vous
allez voir que l'entretien avec jean
michel le lieu on voit qu à voir ensuite
avec valéry giscard d'estaing peut se
lire de deux façons première question la
participation de la france dans la coupe
du monde en argentine en juin penser que
la france passera le 1er tour
ce n'est pas mon rôle de le dire est
prêt à charger le capitaine roux
l'entraîneur président de la fédération
mais est ce que j'ai dit aux joueurs
c'est que pour moi ce qui est important
ce n'était pas s'accrocher uniquement
résultats c'était l'image que l'équipe
de france donnerait à la fois du
football français et en même temps du
comportement des joueurs français avec 7
est à certains égards outil important
est peut-être plus importante le
résultat le métier de sélectionneur
consiste à savoir faire un bon choix
c'est ce qu'a fait michel hidalgo depuis
deux ans depuis qu'il dirige l'équipe de
france de football ça consiste aussi à
savoir réunir différentes tendances
venues d'horizons diverses que
finalement ce n'est pas un portrait
intéressant et bien surtout que je suis
de hugo est un très bon sélectionneur
par la manière dont il règle le problème
que vous est bloquée et avec les arrière
pensées qui sont les vôtres et moi c'est
le rôle d'arbitré d'un rôle ingrat et
difficile je parle d'espoir nous avons
parlé souvent du problème de l'arbitrage
d'autant plus que récemment il ya eu des
discussions vous savez sur des problèmes
d'arbitrage et je crois que le rôle
d'arbitré waterloo sport est difficile
parce que les joueurs me disais qu'au
fond l'arbitré contre lui parce que tout
le monde il envers le public et il a
également les joueurs est néanmoins son
rôle est nécessaire c'est le président
une dernière question le départ de
platini en 79 figurera au chapitre des
exportations françaises
sur le plan économique je parle
non vous comprendrez que je n'ai pas à
intervenir dans des questions de
personnes et il appartient à chacun
d'eux d'apprécier les conditions dans
lesquelles doivent se poursuivant son
activité ce que je souhaite c'est que
les conditions générales d'organisation
du football en france permettent à nos
meilleurs joueurs dont naturellement
platini de rester le plus longtemps
possible
parmi deux dernières questions si la
dam-en-terre si la france si l'équipe de
france se qualifie pour la finale de la
coupe du monde est-ce que vous iriez en
argentine non je n'y aura pas en
argentine je perçois dire je souhaite
que beaucoup de français il ya et bien
entendu c'est loin les conditions
d'accès ne sont pas faciles mais je
suivrai comme tous nos compatriotes
les combats de l'étude de l'équipe de
france et je partagerai leurs voeux pour
son succès et voila quoi que nous
fassions nous en revenons toujours à la
politique
aujourd'hui la politique c'est d'abord
un chiffre car en campagne une
statistique est toujours politique c'est
le taux d'inflation pour le mois de
janvier
un bon indice pour le gouvernement 0 5%
un indice que je vous demande de détail
et philippe sassier oui c'est
effectivement un bon indice mais avant
je voudrais rappeler d'un mot ce que
c'est que cet indice
il englobe au total environ un millier
de produits divers et ils représentent
les dépenses moyennes d'une famille de
français moyens pour se nourrir se loger
se vêtir s'amuser alors maintenant
qu'est ce que l'on peut dire de cet
indice 0 5% en janvier nous étions à 0
3% en décembre 0 4% en novembre anne à
10 en volume elles ne signifient pas
grand chose mais ce sont les tendances
qui sont importants en trois mois et
bien le taux d'inflation annuel de la
france et de -2 5% ça donc c'est bon en
six mois -2 7% et ça aussi c'est la
preuve que il y a un net coup de frein
qui est donnée à l'inflation en france
alors lundi du mois de janvier de quoi
est il fait l'alimentation a monté de 0
5%
l'industrie est très sage 0,3 pour cent
les services 0,7 pour cent c'est la plus
forte hausse et les due notamment aux
loyers qui augmentent et c'est en
général toujours le cas en janvier de
1,2 pour cent maintenant je voudrais
faire deux remarques
la première c'est que les français
commencent véritablement à ressentir ce
coup de frein dans l'inflation et par
exemple la dernière enquête de l'insee
auprès des ménages indique que les
français sont moins pessimistes en ce
qui concerne la situation économique
la seconde remarque c'est que au mois de
juin
en général il ya des hausses très forte
là ne sont pas produisent et les
tensions inflationnistes ont quand même
pas disparu en février par exemple vous
le savez à cause du froid et légumes ont
augmenté à cause de la dévaluation du
franc vers qui est dû à la baisse
d'autres france par rapport à d'autres
monnaies et bien certains autres
produits comme le lait le yaourt le
fromage ont augmenté vous savez qu'on
avril il y aura une augmentation du prix
des tarifs publics et vous savez qu'en
février par exemple le prix des voitures
également augmenté alors justement j'ai
envie de vous demander si ça va
continuer après les élections c'est ce
que c'est pas un indice qui dément elle
est orale non c'est un cetain cette
analyse ce qui reflète bien une tendance
on l'a vu tout à l'heure maintenance
conserve et mois qui vont venir lundi
c'est quand même un indicateur d'une
certaine politique économique d'une
certaine discipline l'on peut s'imposer
dans un pays évidemment 'l'indice après
le mois d'avril sortira de la politique
qu'adoptera la future majorité me
parliez à l'instant l'automobile c'est
toujours un thermomètre intéressant rire
marche bien pour avoir à changer de
mobile
nous les aimons bien ça laisse
économique un chiffre 42,2 milliards
c'est le montant total des exportations
c'est un record d automobile française
en 1977
elles ont augmenté de plus de 20% ses
exportations l'empêchent faut dire que
raymond barre avait donné cette
information sur le taux d'inflation de
janvier à l'heure du déjeuner devant les
membres du cercle de l'opinion et il
s'est à son tour prononcé sur cette idée
que nous avions lancé un face-à-face
mitterrand barre vous savez qu'il y a
deux jours françois mitterrand c'est un
petit peu moqué du premier ministre ont
seulement dans quelle raison il pourrait
bien trouver à le rencontrer aujourd'hui
raymond barre reprendre à son compte la
même argumentation et il lui retourne
son ironie la vente hier
écoutez en ce qui concerne monsieur
mitterrand gelé déjà rencontré et tout
le monde s'en souvient
oui
monsieur mitterrand aussi
j'ajoute d'ailleurs conçu concerne
monsieur mitterrand j'avais rencontrés
la dernière fois comme leader reconnu de
l'opposition unie cela serait plus
difficile cette fois il paraît que je
suis le premier ministre d'un
gouvernement moribond et que cela n'est
pas intéressant de rencontrer un
personnage de la sorte
et bien moi je peux dire que par rapport
à mai dernier je rencontrerai un leader
moribond de l'union moribonde de la
gauche unie
on arrête avec nous de marseille gaston
defferre garçons de faire merci d'être
notre invité ce soir alors monsieur le
maire moribond de la gauche voilà qu'à
nouveau la majorité semble remonter dans
les sondages
l'écart entre la majorité et
l'opposition n'a pas diminué
il est toujours de 5 à 6% conséquent je
ne pense pas que l'on puisse dire
loin de là que l'opposition et la gauche
soit moribonde
est ce que vous pensez comme le gaston
defferre comme pardon comme pierre lors
de mon roi l'a dit ce matin dans le
matin de paris que le pc va se désister
il se déclare pratiquement certain que
le pcva se désister entre les deux tours
c'est une question d'appréciation
personnelle
il n'est pas possible de se prononcer en
mon avis de façon certaine avant le
premier tour et peut-être même avant le
milieu de la semaine entre le premier et
le deuxième tour voudrais rappeler qu'en
1967 là qu'il n'y ait pas de programme
comme le parti communiste à respecter la
discipline républicaine et même qu'il a
retiré certains de ses candidats arrivés
en tête au profit des candidats
socialistes pour qu'il puisse battre la
droite
on n'en est pas là pour l'instant un
pardon mais c'est un souvenir qui n'est
peut-être pas inutile de rappeler
qu'elles sont de faire parler un petit
peu des institutions la gauche au
pouvoir est ce que c'est le retour au
régime des partis comme laisser un petit
peu entendre le président leur public
1 certainement pas et en tout cas si
retour des partis au pouvoir il ya c'est
déjà fait 40 chirac
les effets des pères laisser des jeunes
c'est quoi véritablement l'assistant une
sorte de valse hésitation des partis de
la majorité qui joue maintenant un rôle
essentiel pour parler aussi d'une
institution est ce que vous êtes
vraiment sûr comme vous laissiez
entendre il ya deux semaines que le
présent république peut vraiment nommer
des ministres communistes à l'huile le
faire c'est à lui de prendre cette
décision
j'ai appelé à quelques semaines le texte
de la constitution article vite
qui dit le président de la république
nomme le premier ministre
il n'a monsieur propre proposition du
premier ministre les ministres
ceci dit il ya le fait politique si la
gauche gagne les élections
cela voudra dire que les électeurs ont
choisi un gouvernement avec les musées
socialistes radicaux et communistes en
effet le programme s'appelle le
programme commun du gouvernement de la
gauche et ne n'ont pas cessé de dire les
uns et les autres qu'il devrait y avoir
dans ce cas des ministres les trois
formations politiques
par conséquent une pression d'un public
ça en face d'un choix fait par la
majorité des électeurs et il devra en
tenir compte et ce gouvernement quel en
sera le chef certains disent maintenant
que ce pourrait être vous et non par
françois mitterrand comme on le croyait
jusqu'à lors françois mitterrand est le
leader incontesté du parti socialiste et
il est aussi qu'on le veuille ou non le
leader de la gauche je ne le suis pas
par conséquent je n'ai pas les qualités
de françois mitterrand pour devenir
premier ministre
juste un mot pour terminer gaston
defferre les français sont saturés
politiques nous disent encore d'autres
sondages il aimerait qu'on leur parle de
sécurité pour parce que vous en
politique vous n'en parlait jamais et
bien j'en ai parlé un peu télévision que
en face de monsieur bonnet sevaille sur
antenne 2 et ils on parle tous les jours
dans mes réunions je n'en parlais dans
une réunion électorale il ya quelques
minutes
je voudrais à ce propos rappelé que les
français ce sondage le révèle attache
énormément d'importance à la sécurité
si on veut rétablir une sécurité qui a
disparu c'est michel droit qui a rappelé
il ya quelques temps à france inter et
que le nombre de crimes crapuleux avait
augmenté en quinze ans de 3000% c'est
alain peyrefitte le garde des sceaux qui
a happé dans son rapport que de 53 à
le nombre de délits et les crimes
avaient diminué et qu'il avait
recommencé à augmenter à partir de 1960
se tamisent la vème république qui le
dit il faut s'en prendre aux causes
c'est à dire supprimer le chômage
supprimer la misère il faut résoudre le
problème de la ségrégation dans les
grandes villes
ce que la majorité n'a pas voulu dire
quand nous avons présenté des
propositions de municipalisation des
terrains à bâtir des propositions de
création d'un impôt foncier qui comme
dans tous les pays évolués aurait permis
de créer un marché foncier nos
propositions ont été repoussés et bien
si nous avons un gouvernement
nous ferons tout cela nous combattrons
chômage
nous supprimerons dont l'essentiel des
causes de la délinquance et de la
criminalité est aussi nous renforçons la
police car il faut qu'elle soit présente
pour exercer une action préventive si il
y avait dans les rues des rondes et
patrouilles de police irait moins
d'attac moins de cambriolages mois de
vol
si la police et des plus nombreuses
elles retrouvaient plus facilement les
auteurs des vols et des cambriolages et
des assassinats et par conséquent elle
exercerait pleinement son rôle et les
français se sentira en sécurité bien
gars sont deux frères jonas une
suggestion du gaulliste pierre lefranc
interrogé par leurs vues l'appel en cas
de victoire de la gauche que monsieur
giscard d'estaing démissionne puis se
représente pour vos cils et puis comme
chaque soir un autre regard sur la
politique nos enquêtes dans les
circonscriptions hier soir nous étions
outre mer avec bernard pradines au reste
on y met de guadeloupe nous passons en
guyane là bas on se sent encore plus
éloigné de la métropole et donc
peut-être un peu moins concernés par le
scrutin des 12 et 19 mars
résultat une tendance marquée à
l'abstention
madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir non
comme chaque soir à la politique
intérieure malgré la fin de la semaine à
6000 km de paris yves rambo journalistes
à fr3 parle de politique exactement
comme si des têtes en métropole georges
marchais continue lui attaqué de toute
part il a proposé à françois mitterrand
néanmoins une nouvelle rencontre
il est peu probable que la réponse du
parti socialiste sera positive à
l'examen l'impact des informations
typiquement parisienne est très faible
en guyane pour un département grand
comme la bretagne
on ne compte que 50 5000 habitants et 22
mille électeurs
la guyane nelly qu'un seul député c'est
le même depuis 67
monsieur rivière est gaulliste contre
lui lui mois prochain un seul candidat
de poids un socialiste madame et
monsieur à risque elle est employée de
banque il est infirmier représente un
couple d'électeurs moyens pas très
motivé il est vrai que l'assemblée
nationale est bien loin
monts et merveilles en fait ta vision
sur place et puis surtout ce très loin
du pays qu'ils ont vite oublié ou alors
ils peuvent pas
pourquoi loiret
non non et il est très rare que leurs
promesses bonjour et à l'encontre adp
qui nous avait promis un train un trait
anguleux nous attend nous faire tirer
comme argument électoral n'est pas
malade aurait fait de nous proposer des
écoles vision de l'apprentissage
pour ce témoin là mais en fait ça nous
emmène madame gallimard qui est indienne
vite avec toute sa famille près de
cayenne
elle est plus que sceptique était partie
des 50% des électeurs guyanais qui
s'abstiennent de voter allez voter pour
le député pourquoi vous ne votez pas
ça vous intéresse pas ou n'avaient pas
confiance dans la politique oui et pas
confiance et vous qu'est ce que vous
faites là tous les jours fait cogner
contre les colis sont très jolis
d'ailleurs à l'est et les jeunes gens ça
les intéresse vos enfants vos petits
enfants vous par exemple vous avez quel
âge vous avez le droit d'ôter par
conséquent oui il a des raisons de le
faire non jamais ce qui préoccupe les
guyanais ce sont les prix tout ou
presque vient de la métropole et le coût
du transport fait augmenter
considérablement le prix du kilo de
pommes de terre le gouvernement
actuellement dépensent des sommes
énormes pour indemniser les
fonctionnaires sous prétexte que la vie
est chère
si on disposait de cette masse
l'argent ce supplément de salaire pour
financer le transport de marchandises
qui grève considérablement leur prix est
bien le problème serait résolu absolvant
peu de vie chère on vendrait
pratiquement tous au même prix que
l'enfance etc d'une proposition qui est
faite par les partis ou les candidats
politiques aux élections ici écoutez je
vais relire pas connaissance parce que
j'avais tous les gens qui tentent dans
la politique
ils sont intéressés à ce problème là en
tant que précisément fonctionnaires plus
ou moins
élections le mois prochain mais d'abord
le carnaval la fête traditionnelle à
laquelle tout le pays y participent y
compris les grands de la politique dans
une danse beaucoup plus fraternel qui
respectueuse la dernière information
politique c'est un rendez vous que je
vous donne demain avec simone veil qui
sera l'invité de jean-pierre elkabbach
dans samedi ennemis demain donc à 12h30
bientôt des numéros de téléphone à huit
chiffres partout en france un plan de
restructuration qui pourrait voir le
jour dès octobre la france serait divisé
en cinq zones le 16 et le k1 serait
supprimé et remplacé par le zéro puis le
numéro de votre zone
puis vous huit numéros je pense que nous
en reparlerons d'ici là un mois de
prison avec sursis pour l'automobiliste
qui avait refusé d'ouvrir son coffre à
un contrôle policier au moment des
recherches sur la sphère en pain et un
évidemment c'est une condamnation qui
fait sursauter car jusqu alors la
plupart d'entre nous pensaient qu'on
pouvait légalement s'opposer à une fuite
de nos véhicules
mais vos recettes ça n'est pas si simple
que cela
cette voiture est à moi est elle pour
autant en 1978 une partie intégrante de
ma vie privée de mon domaine privé sur
ce point le droit semble plus rigide que
le bon sens en gros trois personnes
peuvent demander à fouiller votre
voiture les douaniers les agents du
trésor et les pôles les officiers de
police judiciaire
c'est à dire les membres de la police
judiciaire il le justifie
les policiers ont une carte les
gendarmes ont une plaque les simples
agents de police ne sont pas des hauts
pays et ne peuvent donc pas agir seuls
mais ils peuvent appeler à noter j où
vous emmener au commissariat
voir à nos pays et c'est là que la tente
peut commencer les douaniers et les
agents du trésor peuvent fouiller tout
le monde et tout le temps les officiers
de police judiciaire ne peuvent agir que
dans le cadre d'une procédure de
flagrant délit c'est à dire tout de
suite après le hold-up le kidnapping ou
le crime mais cette procédure peut se
poursuivre plusieurs jours car on
considère que c'est la même opération
qui continue ensuite le juge
d'instruction peut décider de demander
par commission rogatoire aux policiers
de continué de fouiller ce que vous ne
pouvez pas refuser cela c'est le droit
qui vise à limiter les abus et les excès
mais si vous n'avez rien à cacher et
qu'on vous le demande poliment surtout
autant gagner du temps encore un nouveau
repli du dollar à paris il est
aujourd'hui à 476 le front ne bouge pas
et le mark s'effrite légèrement le franc
suisse lui monte encore à tel point que
la suisse a dû prendre des mesures pour
enrayer cet hoax chine au lendemain de
la réunion du comité central du parti
communiste un petit début de culte de la
personnalité walk of fame le premier
chinois semblent vouloir mieux se faire
connaître de son peuple
une campagne d'apparitions publiques qui
a commencé avant-hier et voici
maintenant une bien étrange façon de
vous parler de politique étrangère je
vais le faire à l'aide de ces petites
bêtes qui je l'espère ne vont pas trop
vous effrayer ce sont décryptés pèlerins
depuis des siècles depuis les sept
plaies d'égypte
on sait qu'un nuage de criquets
représentent un fléau inimaginable elles
sont tellement vorace que se croiser ce
fléau finalement on ne croyait
complètement maîtrisé en fait il n'était
depuis 17 ans mais voilà qu'à nouveau
on le croire reparaître dans la corne de
l'afrique et à cause des combats très
violents qui s'y déroulent actuellement
dans l'ogaden
personne ne peut plus aller combattre ce
nuage d'insectes ces deux milliards de
criquets s'il se pose sur des cultures
c'est le désastre tout disparaît comment
cette espèce de sauterelle d'habitude
solitaire d'un seul coup se multiplient
pour former un nuage dévastateur la
réponse des savants il ya certaines
conditions exceptionnelles où les pluies
alors se met à tomber dans les endroits
assez vaste à l'heure où la végétation
démarre tout de suite ça fait des
pâturages et les criquets il avant
profitent alors ce sont des bsa qui me
produise en laboratoire des pontes de
centaines d'un fin tous les 4-5 jours et
ça pendant un mois un mois et demi il
falloir si les conditions sont bonnes
parce tous voilà ça fait une
reproduction des explications troubles
les scientifiques ont mis longtemps
avant de savoir où et pourquoi se former
c'est est ce un énorme de criquets
pèlerins cela se produit généralement
sur les bords de la mer rouge et les
nuages de criques et se répandent à
travers une partie de l'afrique et du
moyen-orient au gré des vents
le soir lorsqu'un essaims se pose pour
manger ses 4000 tonnes de végétaux au
moins qui sont ainsi engloutis chaque
jour le criquet adultes manche son poids
de nourriture alors un essaim normal de
ces terribles bestioles mange la
nourriture d'un million de personnes
chaque jour
l'amérique est aussi touchée par une
autre espèce de criquets un peu plus
petit plutôt sombre mais tout aussi
vorace depuis 17 ans les nations unies
ont réussi à enrayer ce fléau en
empêchant les criques et de se
reproduire
au départ cela a été possible parce que
sur le terrain des hommes ont repéré
observer et détruit les foyers de
développement
mais aujourd'hui dans la corne de
l'afrique
c'est la guerre et aucun spécialiste ne
peut approcher les zones menacées
alors on craint le pire
une multiplication foudroyante des
criquets après la famine endémique et la
guerre ce sera peut-être les sauterelles
et on verra encore une fois c'est visage
décharné d'êtres humains mourant de faim
le redoux qui règne en france depuis
deux jours provoquent maintenant de
nombreuses inondations surtout dans le
sud ouest c'est dans la région
parisienne dans la capitale et berges
qui longe la seine sont inondées et les
crues sont à l'origine de ce spectacle
étrange ce matin un bateau s'est
retrouvé décapité de son chapeau de
plexiglas la scène étant à son niveau
maximum le bateau mouche n'a pas pu
passer entier sous le pont dalmat
c'est-à-dire tout juste à côté de la
maison de la radio de la télévision et
je ne parle pas des péniches qui l ont
parfois dû rompre leurs amarres alors un
moment où
la dernière des zones scolaires c'est à
dire la région parisienne prend ses
vacances et où je vous recommande une
fois de plus de ne pas partir de la
capitale demain entre 4 heures du matin
et quatre heures l'après midi nous avons
eu envie de savoir quel temps il va
faire ce week end et il faut d'abord que
je vous tire les oreilles monsieur météo
parce que lundi vous étiez là vous nous
aviez annoncé un temps de chien du
verglas delaney j sais pas c'est tout le
contraire
oui effectivement je dois reconnaître
une grosse erreur c'est à dire que
j'avais prévu du temps froid pour la fin
de semaine et c'est tout le contraire
bon alors les prévisions qu'on va faire
maintenant sont bonnes alors les
prévisions nous espérons d'or sont
bonnes avec des pluies qui viennent de
l'ouest qui vont gagner demain une
grande partie de la france et surtout
insisté sur des vents forts avec de
fortes rafales dès la nuit prochaine
atteignant 70 à 80 km heure près de
l'atlantique les fera doux naïfs radio
pour d'immenses c'est encore du temps
doux mais toutefois avec des pluies
venant de l'ouest et des vents forts
pour le ski hors piste la plus grande
prudence et ce même déconseillé de faire
du ski hors piste car pour l'instant le
manteau neigeux est très fragile et les
vents restent fort en altitude et sur la
semaine à venir le renouveau début de
semaine devrait donner un peu d'eux un
rafraîchissement est à nouveau des
pluies et des vents forts dans le
courant de la semaine prochaine
je remercie les spurs avaient juste vous
propose maintenant des images
renversantes ça se passe aux
championnats du monde de ski en finlande
et je ne vous en dis pas plus regardez
ce qui va venir c'est à dire le numéro
et voilà on va revoir cela au ralenti il
faut quand même que je vous dise que le
sauteur s'est retrouvé presque indemne
un peu choqué quand même mais il n'a
même pas été hospitalisé regardez cette
chute
et il a même perdu son casque et il
n'est même pas traumatisé voilà 22h40
c'est gérard holtz qui fera le dernier
point de l'actualité je vous souhaite
une très bonne soirée j'aurai le plaisir
de vous retrouver mardi
mais je voudrais vous laisser sur une
bonne impression sur un spectacle sur
glace où là on ne tombe pas holiday on
ice à paris jusqu'au 8 mai beaucoup de
strass de paillettes de costumes et de
dollars le reste c'est de la glace des
flocons de neige
un sapin de noël 15 panthère rose des
valses de vienne des chimpanzés et des
champions de pouzauges cet homme de 65
ans ce champion professionnel donne
pendant 11 années consécutives
et le super craquant drège des pelles à
huit fois champion de tchécoslovaquie
cinq fois champion d'europe
trois fois champion du monde enfin
champion olympique et poursuit hors
piste ses études de droit
voilà ce journal est terminée bonsoir à
marty
et